talk about obviously getting dark on the
record Dirk is out we just had a
conversation with little Zay Osama about
Dirk and like
he's kind of like uh you know we talk
about the Drake stimulus package there's
the Dirk stimulus package like if Dirk
gets on your [ __ ] these days it's a big
deal like right like uh how did that
happen [ __ ] yeah hit me up he's yeah hit
me like two months ago like send me a
line he wanted to um like put me on his
Deluxe at first he was like yo I'm
trying to put you in my Deluxe you feel
me send me like two to three opens I
sent them cute but I sent him a song
called lineman that I got out right now
and another song but when I sit through
them you know like the sample [ __ ] and
all that type stuff so he was like damn
I just talked to my CEO he basically
said he might not be able to clear it on
time type [ __ ] so I'm like all right but
[ __ ] are we gonna do something so long
story short
like a week go by later he performing at
Summer Jam and [ __ ] I'm backstage Summer
Jam by myself
feel me I heard I heard I'm like yo Dirk
you feel me dirt coming out I'm like oh
dirty people performing because he's
like he wanted to really lock in with me
like on some ATL Metro [ __ ] right right
so like once I heard he was there a
straight face timing I'm like where you
at you're like I don't even know bro she
I flipped my camera I was right in front
of the [ __ ] trailer yeah pulled me in
on that drawing this [ __ ] kind of like
400 000 in my face bust down and all
that type [ __ ] kid 40 000 in cash in
here yeah yeah he yeah is that what they
paid him to do something I don't know
that [ __ ] I was like oh that [ __ ] real
you feel me so once I seen that shot I
asked him about the record and [ __ ] he
said like he he like a little iffy about
it but he was like I really want to do
something from scratch with you but I'm
like all right [ __ ] it bang like a week
go by later and [ __ ] man we always kept
telling we talk like every day so I text
him I woke up one morning like [ __ ] it
I'm gonna shoot my shot again I text you
I'm like yo Broski like how much I gotta
give you to hop on this song and you
text me back to like no he didn't text
me he called me later on like seven
o'clock taking probably like 12 o'clock
in the afternoon he called me like yo
brosky I got my own daughter on the
phone
and he was like show your face like she
don't believe that I know who he was I
show my face I'm like you know she
starts smiling and I'm like damn like
what the [ __ ] she don't know who I'll
pop is real for real but after that I'm
like hey bro how much you want to really
out with a dog you like send me that
[ __ ] right now I'm in the lab she sent
me that [ __ ] over like the next hour and
it was up so did you have to pay him no
I didn't so he just did it on the street
and he did that big deal man that [ __ ]
a [ __ ] cash me out for my birthday all
type [ __ ] you gave me money yeah what
kind of like what what's the birthday
gift looking like she gave me five grand
five bands yeah was this at a strip club
or was this just oh is that the video
shoot wow
what'd you do with the five bands
son you want to talk about that [ __ ] bro
what happened what happened with the
money
give me the story I tell you this [ __ ]
bro that [ __ ] the 90th [ __ ] hey I want
to think this didn't even know so bang
module had a fire racks all Blues you
feel me I I have probably like two to
three wrecks you feel me on the side I
put together with that [ __ ] I'm on Ocean
Drive okay so you're in Miami
um on the liquor yeah yeah we all
fronting there should I have my money on
the side of the car and [ __ ] my homie
was playing with my money my only was
playing my money and [ __ ] my brother
peeped it so bang after that [ __ ] like
after I came out my brother told me I
put this [ __ ] in the glove Department my
money ordered my homie and stood that
[ __ ] so I had um put the money in the
glove Department I hopped on this
[ __ ] Zoom call and [ __ ] I fall asleep
after the zoom call me right to the
airport bro I leave my money in a
[ __ ] car bro please bro I ain't
noticed it's like 20 to 30 minutes later
bro I try to run back I hop on the
shuttle bus I came back hey yo unlock
the door right now they unlock the door
I go in the glass apartment it took all
my hundreds bro and left me once
I'm making them into these pockets all
types of [ __ ] bro you just snapping this
[ __ ] literally part like four days ago
like Jesus I'm snapping so it was five
grand plus more money yeah it was more
money probably like seven thousand for
real for real they came up whoever that
was then he said the [ __ ] that checked
the car and all that he had got off oh
he was gone so I'm like he probably quit
his job he's like [ __ ] this job that's
what I'm saying soon I was hot though I
ain't gonna like [ __ ] [ __ ] me up seven
bands man